se cierra la era de mario draghi en
italia en la mañana de este jueves el
primer ministro presentó su dimisión al
presidente italiano sergio matar el a
una decisión consecuencia de un voto de
confianza en la noche del miércoles en
el parlamento italiano durante el cual
tres de los principales partidos
miembros de la coalición de gobierno-
boicotearon el voto no votaron a la
confianza al gobierno al cual pertenecía
en un gesto que marcó la ruptura en la
coalición de unión nacional que mantenía
en pie el ejecutivo de mario draghi a
partir de ahora será el presidente
italiano sergio matar el a quien
decidirá el destino político del país
podría nombrar un nuevo primer ministro
pero la hipótesis que parece ahora más
probable es que anuncie la disolución
del parlamento y que convoque elecciones
anticipadas que podrían llevarse a cabo
en el mes de septiembre o de octubre
próximo